in this video we have hundreds of
prisoners and they're trying to escape
by the helicopter as you guys can see we
have tons of random minecraft players
here and I don't want any of them to
score we won't let them through yeah
yes sir whichever prisoner scores the
most wins $10,000 we did two of these
before and you guys want a little easy
autumn Chandler stand right here
Carl stand here Chris yes stand here all
right open the gates
Carl don't let any pass Chris don't let
any pass Roger
Chris they're gonna pass across their
passage no who's passing Chris I'm gonna
help i equip the boys with really oh
please snowball help hold them back help
help help
oh well I'm through Chandler don't let
them escape I'm just going through and
putting creepers everywhere
has anyone scored yet I don't think so
let's let some people score everyone
stand out I can't stop I don't know if
the scores working wait how do they
sport this man's in the helicopter no
everyone's in here now die ha ha beat it
beat it start that timer all right 10
seconds Carl you ready for me Chris are
you ready
oh all right Chris is setting up some
mobs ok I'm getting ready okay let's see
if it even get through me all right I'm
gonna put some pillagers up here to
snipe them Carl they're getting through
no no we're good whoa a lot of leg oh
boy jet Ida no no you're not first bro
sorry let's let one person through
they're not scoring from my side yeah
Carl Keith um oh wait here's a Demon
Slayer skin he's going go go go up there
we go
everyone has exactly one point Chris hmm
you're gonna let him through you weep
don't even think about it they're gone
such a good job waiting $10,000 is
supposed to be hard
yeah you shouldn't just waltz right in
and get ten grand and here's the other
thing in this hide-and-seek video we
went easy on someone with besmirch his
damn shot mr. Bies we have to go easier
it's fair and you guys got kind of mad
so you know what that means boys does
that mean no mercy target the besmirched
no mercy no stop having mercy no mercy
stupid gone car it's been gone I'd like
to point out that Chris's defenses are
much slower than mine oh really
everybody's getting deleted every time
Chandler how's your job you know I'll
just be watching the boys Oh Oh Carl one
got through Oh Carl you one got through
no one has scored in five minutes guys I
said we go a little easier on ya I'm
gonna just close my eyes and then I'll
just click the button and whoever dies
dies yeah I'm not gonna move anymore
so I let him go oh hey hey boom
all right Chandler's in first place
because he keeps accidentally walking
into oh my goodness Chandler I'm trying
to let some go through him use
only the sword now Carl switch your
sword let's be nice oh oh my gosh it's
so much harder I'm gonna stand here and
kill people all right there's a lot of
people getting through oh hey it's um
Squidward let's see if they just walk
into my sword whoo handsome Squidward
oh look people are literally just
walking into my sword sorry sorry
everybody sorry everybody I'm killing I
didn't mean to
Oh dharna actually kills handsome
Squidward not an subscribe word yeah I'm
gonna stand here and just whack people
whack whack whack oh okay all right know
what go through go through guys alright
we're going back to being easy on
besmirch wait Carl yes did you dig a
tunnel no Chris did you dig one no I
didn't dig a tunnel Chandler did you
know there's a tunnel here who took this
who Doug dimmadome to that all right
here I'm gonna put lava here just to
screw the cheaters I'm using hacks guys
I'm just blowing up the map now guys I
thought of a genius plan what if we just
did this now they can't xscape wait
where's everything let's see if our
defenses work oh oh how did he do that
oh wait wait how'd they get another
tunnel
oh it's somebody's giving him a tunnel
who's building this stuff I promise it's
actually not me this time so I think
someone's competing wait so you're
saying one of these people competing has
creative Oh we're hitting each other up
they're hitting each other up only the
biggest of the brains are winning right
now ten seconds left
come on guys ten grands on the line I'm
putting creepers to blow people in there
all right round over como como round one
is over everyone is trapped here open
the gates boys let's show them what
round twos gonna be about we have this
insane obstacle course for them to go
through but the thing is we left the
sides open so they don't actually have
to do this obstacle course but if they
go around the side to have to deal with
Chris or coral so this is what the mazes
they climb up here they bounce they go
here they jump they climb then they jump
jump climb up if you miss it you got to
start over and then you get up here and
you jump into the water go through the
middle what are you doing guys you're
gonna die well I mean they have options
it's so weird because the same thing
we'll keep going through there and dying
like you think they would learn after a
while what we're trying to do here is
not make this straightforward we're
trying to have intelligence play a role
the left and the right side are open but
every five seconds creepers explode oh
man so how many times are they gonna try
to go through here before they go
through the only open path a bunch of
silly willies they're hitting each other
in the lava bill it way through
currently is the obstacle course the
left and right side are just illusions
oh wait oh wait he made it through whoa
Haley there is a way to get through I am
the judger
I judge currently croisine is in first
with a decent lead you know what this
obstacle course is too easy I'm gonna
make it harder all right
like always since this is second round
they get 20 points per score the blazes
they're like dodgeball throwing at them
you guys are so cruel this is ten grand
it's not supposed to be easy
Chandler I have a plan come with me okay
let's destroy some of this glass and
snipe through it shot mr. beast already
won a video yeah that's right you better
burn make sure no previous winners win
target them yeah we hate previous yeah
targeting whoa croisine you will not a
new wave is spawning through I kept them
in spawn for a little while now they're
coming through as hard as they can
Boyka Pinkus zoink u-joint you you know
what sucked for these people were
getting by some blazes uh-oh shot mr.
beast
kill them kill him do not let him win
again I got him I got him in the butt oh
no that guy got killed by creepers I
feel bad that was all my fault
there's always be saying he feels bad
right after doing something very
intentionally a lot of people just made
it through the right side yeah the right
side apparently can be exploited if you
hug the wall is that how Castro no I got
a head yeah only the smartest survive
man all right let's make this way harder
let's put creepers all over all right I
gotta get some let's get a couple of
these bad boys all right what a ghast in
here why are there just gas
wouldn't it be rude to put a Ravager in
the maze what if I did this look the gas
is blocking the entrance right here oh
my god he's sitting there chilling what
this is probably the hardest one we've
ever done currently I've blocked off all
paths there's no way to score wait these
people are just
taking damage through the lava with him
old lame or Carl
Chandler you guys go see if you could
score all you guys play oh come on a
blaze hit me in midair
wait there's only 20 seconds left I'm
gonna do it it creative I'll do it and
creative let me see
I'm doing oh I just didn't fly them up
the ladder I guess
oh no I'm doing it I'm doing it
rounds over no more scoring no more
scoring no more scoring no more story
Jimmy will get made it to the end that
is the end of round 2 Chris how do you
feel I feel like we've got a really good
job accomplished we didn't let hardly
anyone through Castro you are currently
in the lead with 200 points as of right
now you would hypothetically win the 10
grand if the video was over how does
that make you feel I'm feeling pretty
confident money if you lost would you be
sad why don't you stand you know no ran
three just walk away right now just
you're right actually let's do that
that's it for this video
I'm blocking off this side of the map
and I'm blocking off this side of the
map Carl I want you to join in the
competition and see if you can win Oh
bye okay boy Jedi I know I've been
killing you but now I'm on your team now
before we start the third round Chris
Chandler come over here let's switch to
survival mode and let's see if we can
beat this what just show you how it's
done I want us to attempt this so we
understand what they're going through
all right thanks a lot Chris Chris hey
hey dude oh how are you supposed to get
that jump all you got to be hop it
alright I know what to do
Oh Chandler got it Oh do you guys
respect it contestants more now uh nah
I'm gonna try one more time boom boom
then you come here then you go bada boom
bada BAE Wow anyways the point is this
is really hard so whoever gets this
money deserves it go to the end and make
this way harder do whatever you want
say no more start the next round left
side is blocked off right side is
blocked off one way through $10,000 okay
this might be a little bit illegal but I
like to cheat because I've never won yo
this last round is worth a lot more
points good luck everybody and they're
off to the races let's see how it goes I
don't know why these people think that
they can get through over this way they
can't but we're gonna hide here for a
second so nobody sees us do this
oh I can't place a block they're all
falling dude whoever makes it through is
just pure luck
Oh hockey buns hockey buns hockey but no
oh this guy or whatever its ik what he's
a guy huh
okay I actually want to try okay oh can
he make that complicated jump yeah
oh no don't stand in it you got a jump
I'm sad this is impossible this is the
new segment I call Chris trying to
pronounce names Chris what's this guy's
name
uh that guy is a growed what's this
guy's name
his name is Jim am prov oh wait drum
said it what's this guy's name that is
um le no that's um dead and that
concludes Chris trying to pronounce
names you guys have no idea how
difficult this is it's like everybody's
working against each other there's
people that have sacrificed winning
$10,000 just to make sure nobody else
can get through I'm so annoyed the
target Karl ah they're giving up their
chance to win money just to make me sad
guys you guys stay over there so it's
not too suspicious
I'm going to make a secret tunnel oh wow
wait there chasey karl is literally come
to spawn Christy p2b planet there's
people literally chasey like they have
Carlton town they're going after it why
are they going to have to him stop haha
you noob wait I got a hold up let me try
that no
oh we should a hundred percent just pay
them just for doing I should hire
someone just to kill Carl every I will
kill you I'll murder you all this is a
last round that's four minutes left this
is where they spawned I'm gonna do a
super secret thing damn he'll see if he
doesn't let's see if Carl does it
[Music]
Donham oh my god somebody was making me
a tunnel hahaha
Chris make a bunch a quote unquote
secret tunnels but it's just holes
secret tunnel initiative he just he just
walked away from it
oh he felt Castro is still in first he
did manage to score look at all this
right here isn't this beautiful
oh look a diamond on the ground give me
that oh my Chris time to just literally
pull holes in the ground that if they go
in they're stuck I'm just gonna wait for
Carl to come out and snipe them every
time I see you you fall in the hole you
die
Carl's flying comes flying whoa cheater
let me move out the way you know what
about the type go ahead and type it sir
/ban what'd ya get banned nerd then I
want to teach you to cheat nor minecraft
server why you cheated no somebody else
was on my account guys five minutes left
open up the sides hurry let's let some
people squirt open up a side handler let
people's score you know amit has won
before oh no we can't have it om it's
about the score Amit just scored twenty
seconds left I'll do the creepers a ten
seconds to left oh my gosh
five seconds left
um I cannot believe Amit won again
but see the viewers are gonna think
we're Vitus no we literally killed
everyone we solved we showed no bias to
be clear you're saying you're not biased
you just spent like ten minutes of that
round just trying to kill me Amit what
happened why do you keep winning you
want me to tell the secret yes I
literally said to myself oh yeah that's
just playful fun I didn't even thought
about winning you know just another day
in the life of a gamer a mess for the
rest of the challenges we are
handicapped at you you're not allowed to
win more money I'm gonna join the disk
or chat see what everyone's saying all
right well thank you guys for coming out
hit the subscribe button and we'll see
you in the next video